the Navy SEALs are one of the highest
performing organizations on the planet
and a former Navy SEAL was asked who
makes it through buds who makes it
through the selection process to become
a seal and he said I can't tell you who
gets through who makes it but I can tell
you the kind of people who don't make it
he said the star college athletes that
never have been really tested to the
core of their being none of them make it
through he said the preening leaders who
like to delegate everything none of them
make it through he said the big tough
guys that come in with huge muscles
covered in tattoos I want to prove to
everyone how tough they are none of them
make it through he said some of the guys
that make it through are skinny and
scrawny he said some of the guys who
make it through you will see them
shivering out of fear he said but every
single one of them who makes it through
when they're emotionally exhausted when
they're physically exhausted someway
somehow they're able to dig down deep
inside themselves to find the energy to
help the person next to them service
service giving to another having their
back is what makes the highest
performing teams in the world not their
strength and not their intelligence if
their willingness to be there for each
other
you